- Morgan!
- Momma, don't you have maternity clothes.
- Yeah!
Great idea!
- That's why you save that shit girl!
- Ta-Da!
- Oh, it's perfect!
No one will even know.
- Yeah, genius.
Fuck pants.
- Fuck 'em.
(upbeat music)
- Can you hand me the hair dryer?
- Yeah.
- Thanks.
- Paper towels too.
- Don't forget the wipes.
- Hey, I'm going to go potty.
Can you grab me a coffee.
- Go ahead.
- Thank you!
- So, can I get two double shot lattes
and do you guys have c-a-k-e?
Okay, let me get a piece
of chocolate c-a-k-e.
- Oh, my God!
Have you gone to Sequoia Park yet?
- No, we haven't gone.
- I heard the AstroTurf is amazing.
- We heard that they have
filtered water fountains.
- What!
- Can we go?
Let's go Sunday, at like
Happy Hour before nap time.
- That sounds great.
- You know you're such a Pinkie Pie.
- Really?
Because I've always
kind of identified more
with Twilight Sparkle and
Rainbow Dash when I'm drunk.
You've got to try this cake, it's so good.
- Mmm, no thanks.
I'm still trying to lose that
ten pounds of baby weight.
- Dude Josephine is
going to be 18 months old
and you look great, come on.
- Okay!
Okay, okay!
More, more!
- This cake is for mommy.
- What do you think?
- Yeah, throw it in.
Oh, don't forget the hanger!